sun sea sand there's just one thing
missing tourists
after weeks of lockdown europeans are
taking their first tentative steps
towards a return to normality but the
tourism industry continues to suffer
empty hotels grounded Airlines and
shuttered resorts show the extent of the
damage the pandemic has inflicted on
countries and livelihoods which depend
on tourism we have never seen so the
crisis the european tourism right now
you have to know that there are about 25
million jobs in the european tourism it
means 25 million workers and more than 5
million jobs are in danger the industry
is already benefiting from a series of
steps taken by the EU it has made rules
on landing slots for Airlines more
flexible the sector is being supported
by the coronavirus response initiative a
relaxation of state aid rules and to the
European globalization adjustment fund
for travelers and holiday makers the EU
has updated passenger rights guidelines
to ensure they're treated fairly and
repatriated tens of thousands of
stranded EU citizens but members of
parliament are calling for more a
comprehensive tourism action plan to
coordinate the EU response the plan
should include financial support to help
jobs a crisis management mechanism to
plot a way out of the crisis and
provisions for repatriating and
compensating travelers where necessary
[Music]